what was the most memorable the most
painful
the most
um
insight laden challenge you had to
overcome to bring nest to life
well
the first thing for me
was making someone care about their
thermostat
right no one considers it they never had
any customer choice they didn't install
it they usually don't even use it
because it's so complicated or what have
you they just like they just they [ __ ]
at it they hide it in the corner
and then they just pay the bill right of
whatever it is right it's totally
unloved unconsidered right so how do you
wake up like i said the virus of doubt
how do you wake that up and get people
going
you know remember every day when you go
in and it's like you're just frustrated
and then you get the bill and you pay
the bill so you have to do that so that
was one thing
i think the other big one was not
delivering you know it was all of it was
hard right it was constrained we had
only so much stuff we were bootstrapped
we didn't have massive funding we didn't
get hundreds of millions of dollars it
was but we did it for the right reasons
but i think the other big part of it was
not just building a disruptive product
because a lot of the people on the team
had done that we knew what we were doing
and and that was
if we
got the design right we could deliver it
with the
enough time
it was getting the disruptive go to
market in other words how to take that
product from the end of the production
line and get it into the customers hands
because there was no retail or customer
choice in thermostats no one even it was
never considered purchase
they never thought they had choice
some guy usually in suspenders and a
butt crack
told them looked around looked at their
house and said um this looks like
somebody who's got is well to do
this thermostat is now going to cost you
350 thank you very much
and you're like i'll take whatever you
give me right
and then it goes into another house it's
worth a hundred dollars was the same
damn thing yeah right so there's no
price transparency there was no choice
you just got what you were given
so how do you go
and and and this was an entrenched
industry that's why there was no in
there was no innovation in it because it
was doing just fine because every house
needed them
the all the installers were programmed
by the the product deliverers by you
know bonuses
and and and bonuses to say you're going
to only carry our product and if you
sell this many you're going to get a
free trip to hawaii
right yeah and for these guys who
install i get a free trip to hawaii
that's dream for them right
so
this whole channel was fully controlled
by the product guys and it was almost
monopolistic in a way
so how do you go around that
so
creating a disruptive go to market
channel
one was direct to consumer right and all
the marketing that was necessary to get
that message across
another one was getting the installation
right
no one was self-installing thermostats
so how do we get enough people who are
early adopters to be able to
self-install them confidently
so they didn't still have to call the
guy to come and install it because then
he would say this is a crap product no i
got the must better product right so you
had to get rid of that friction
and then ultimately how do you get the
people who were not just early adopters
but people who needed to see it and
touch it before they bought it how do
you get that into retail
when
the large brands of the time of
thermostats and home depot and lowe's
had contracts that they couldn't bring
in any other brands
they were owning the channel all the way
to where there was any sort of slight
customer choice and it was really um
contractor choice more than it was and
consumer choice so all of that had to be
innovated along with the product and so
to me that was a huge challenge and
something i had never done most of us
had never done and we had to
to create that was as much as a project
as actually delivering the the product
itself
so it turned out to be a giant hit
[Laughter]
and it was acquired by google for 3.2
billion dollars
as a founder and leader just out of
curiosity in these cases of acquisition
um
is it always a good thing
is there any part of
you and the team that considers saying
no
oh we considered saying no all the way
along the process
right we had all been in big companies
before
um we knew what it was like
and the politics and all the other stuff
and what i came to learn
especially
from phillips because phillips was a
very it was 375 000 people was a big it
was massive company right
and tons of politics and i was like do
we want to go back into the world
because i had so many negative
experiences from that
but then going to apple which was no not
big but it was big enough that it could
have all these dynamics but then when
you saw a leader rise up and get rid of
those dynamics or not allow many of them
to to flourish
then you're like oh with the right
leadership this can be a beautiful
marriage right and so for four months we
were working together with them with
google to make sure that we had the
right leadership and we were going to be
in the right environment that it felt
right
so that happened it absolutely happened
we worked on all the details we didn't
even talk about price
we were talking about
how's the brand going to work who's the
team going to work with how are we going
to get ip how are we going to do
exchanges how are we going to get
budgets and all that stuff done so we
worked through all of that before we
actually sealed any kind of deal because
they were already an investor in the
company so we already knew you know they
knew relatively where their you know the
end point was for the price
so working through all those
prerequisites
i knew that
as a individual product company that was
trying to create a platform
no investors were going to invest in a
platform that could take three four
years and many many hundreds of millions
of dollars to build without all kinds of
new products at the same time
and products that we were having which
were successes but they weren't even
break even yet right we were still
developing them so how are we going to
get more people to fund
all of these things and this platform
that i really want to create
because my worry and i had seen this
many times in silicon valley is these
small startups have bravado and they
said i'm going to take on the big guys
right
with a platform
but when those platform guys show up and
apple says they're going to get in the
house at the time nobody cared
they were they were curiously guys
curious what's nest yeah yeah but apple
wasn't in the market google wasn't in
the market yet
amazon wasn't there microsoft samsung
they were not they were all just that's
curious
right
yeah and i had watched if you said i'm
going to go challenge them
and i'm going to build a platform and
then they all of a sudden one by one go
oh well we're building a platform now
we're building a flower they flooded you
to death fear uncertainty down and the
developers run away and you can't make
that platform so i'm like before the
landscape gets changed on us because
we've attracted so much attention they
announced something we need to change
the landscape on them
[Music]
let's go to the best place where we can
build out the platform have the right
leadership behind us
to help us grow this thing into what the
vision it should be and that's what we
believe we were doing with the the
google acquisition
is it
possible to take on the platforms so you
said there's a lot of startups with
bravado and all that kind of stuff right
doesn't mean
you know james joyce when he was 20 said
i'm going to be the greatest writer of
the 20th century
uh before he wrote anything of value um
you know one of them might be actually
right
[Laughter]
um
yeah in this modern world when you so
first of all people should definitely
uh get your book billed as just just uh
this
giant number of advice on this exact
question of
how to build
cool things how to build a startup how
to all the different stages of that team
and hiring it's mostly human nature it's
not technical it's mostly human nature
behind it and it turns out it's you know
turtles all the way down this human at
the bottom uh
yes so
is it possible
to build startups that take on the big
guys
uh whatever that is of of the modern era
so for now it's these platforms of uh
apple google twitter i don't even know
meta i guess called now sure um is it
possible to take them on absolutely
but you don't take them on on their same
turf
you take them on on the turf they gonna
want to have in the future
right
spotify is a platform it started as an
application is now a platform yeah right
think of wechat
think of all the super apps out there
that are now wallets and delivery
services and travel services and and
transportation services all within an
app yeah
they've innovated in a different level
in a different space that the the
platform companies weren't
right or they you know google was an app
it was an app company it was solving
search and then it became a platform
company apple was solving personal
computing and then it became our iphone
was doing you know uh
um
solving internet browsing all that stuff
and then became a platform company when
the app store was added if you look it
up
there's no such thing as building a
platform company you build a great app
first and then you can expand it and
have the right to become a platform
you